huh that'll trump so carpenter was
already getting his name above the title
before we even had one hit this would be
the equivalent of M night Shyamalan
$0.06 exactly 22 days before the Kennedy
assassination coincidence
Jesus could this house look more
uninviting to trick-or-treaters the
Myers couldn't even bother to put the
jack-o'-lantern on the steps so people
could see it better from the street this
family came to pumpkin placement
correctly you are alone aren't we
Michael's around someplace
Michael's older sister decides I can
have sex with my boyfriend with Michael
around it's not like he'll turn into a
psycho killer if he sees this douchebag
pounding me I gotta go so from the time
the lights went out in Judith's bedroom
to now it's been one minute and eight
seconds and I get 20 seconds of that is
getting clothes off I know this kids in
high school but man I just literally
some weak sauce and not very
long-lasting also after the terrible sex
performance Michael's gonna kill his
sister Michael starts stabbing his
sister and then he turns to his right
and what is he stabbing the air Michael
this is a great reveal and what a fun
unbroken shop to start off at cheap
horror movie I'm removing three scenes
for this also the Myers mask is iconic
but can we all just admit an adult in
this clown costume would have been
equally creepy well day we just found
our son standing here with a bloody
butcher knife in his hand but let's just
stand and stare don't you think we could
refer to it as him
really Miriam just a minute ago you were
complaining about their gibberish I
think the expression is don't throw
stones at crazy people's houses or
something along those lines and it'd be
weird if this simple shot of a matchbook
inspired a white-trash themed reboot of
this series almost 30 years later thank
God that never happens I don't care if
he's from hell or not this guy doesn't
have the strength to open palm shatter a
car window like that he's gone he's gone
from here the evil is gone you see dr.
Loomis this is why nobody takes you
seriously you talk about Michael Myers
and dramatic horror movie terms you know
the truth so you've taken a leap nobody
else is ready to accept you need to
learn how to relay how evil he is
without calling him the evil also how
did you know that was Michael all you
saw was one of the many patients driving
away in the car but you never saw his
face also also how does Michael know how
to drive a car he's been in this joint
since he was six did they put him in the
student driver program don't forget to
drop the key off at the Myers place
I won't they're coming by to look at the
house at 10:30 this is a throwaway line
but brings up the question of what
happens to the potential homebuyers in
just two minutes we will see Michael's
already taken up residence as never
mentioned again and why wouldn't mr.
strode be at the house to show it hadn't
filled Illinois where the California
palms grow like wildflowers I believe
that's the city's motto so 15 years have
gone by and nobody can sell the murder
house why isn't this place been
condemned also you'd think of your
strode Realty you'd get somebody to at
least clean up the exterior a bit and
maybe do a little work inside so you
don't have to rely on Tom Hanks and
Shelley long but it should have
how does crazy-ass Michael Myers drive a
stolen station wagon through two road
blocks without anyone seeing it because
he somehow knows secret mariokart path
to avoid cops because remember this
assholes been in an institution for 15
years has the mind of a child
I don't care how evil he is listen here
dr. Loomis I already said in that I know
this sinning thing is a joke to you but
I take it goddamn seriously and so does
certain Hollywood directors man it'd be
weird if dr. Wynn who's only in this one
scene would show up in say the sixth
film in this franchise and we'd find out
he's a member of a weird cult that
worships Michael Myers thank God that
never happens this is a great shot and
I'd remove us in except how did Michael
know Laurie would be sitting next to a
window for him to stalk so perfectly so
why did he walk from Laurie school to
this kid's school Michaels business is
killing babysitter's so
is this some sort of complex dive into
the human soul where he sees a lot of
himself in the kid and he feels they
need to protect him now I'd like that
but that ain't the truth the truth is
you're the weak and I'm the tyranny of
evil men wait sorry guys let's go on to
the next sin no one will be seated
during the Michael goes back to the car
starts it and drives alongside Tommy
portion of the movie also if this is
supposed to be from Michael's
perspective then why are we looking out
the back window of the car while he's
driving Michael like most asshole
drivers on the road doesn't bother to
signal when he turns right yeah
Haddonfield seems like the type of
culturally relevant town in Illinois
where a sign telling you it's 73 miles
away would be appropriate pay phone is
coming to happen sale because I know him
what Loomis told us earlier Michael
hasn't spoken a word in 15 years since
the murder so what information did he
give Loomis that made him so certain
he'd go back there if he escaped dr.
Loomis conveniently pulling up to the
side of the road where the dead
motorists an abandoned truck and a phone
when are is convenient also how is this
not a crime scene by now no one saw an
abandoned truck on the side of the road
with the door wide open and thought to
check that out in the last few hours
Loomis knows Michael was here because of
the matchbook the nurse used to light
her cigarette but doesn't bother to
check for dead bodies that might have
been a good thing to discover and tell
the police earlier he could even tell
him that there's a sign pointing the way
to Haddonfield from this new murder site
tickets on sale for what just the high
school in general and who would even see
the sign that's practically in a forest
[Music]
Michael was literally going drive by
stalking speed barely faster than you
assholes are walking also there is no
way that Michael could have heard
anything Annie was saying while in a
moving car at that distance
I hate humor is very specific it's
almost like you're saying you'd like the
guy if he didn't own a car but still had
no sense of humor I've got three choices
watch the kids sleep listen to Linda
screw around to talk to you I'm starting
to think Myers later kills Annie to put
her out of her misery
[Music]
Annie was clear looking straight ahead
when Michael was visible so how did she
not see him for a movie that is so good
at elevating tension and suspense with
the use of atmosphere and music jump
scares like this come off even more
annoying you know siloing I guess
everyone's entitled one good scare and a
creepy adult who doesn't understand the
concept of personal space
trick-or-treating at 3:00 in the goddamn
afternoon even if it's like five or six
you are severely limiting your candy
haul if she's been gone all day why the
fuck is this window open so at this
point you call the cops right no okay
carry on rotary phone
wow this turns out to be Lori's friend
Annie who decided to call on her mouth
was full of cereal I didn't even bother
an attempt to say something Judith Miya
Miya Roe 18 Scott clinic during his
important search for Michael Myers dr.
Loomis decides to check out the local
cemetery to see if Michael defiled his
sister's grave which somehow takes
precedence over checking his old
neighborhood first why do they do it
steal tombstones that's a common
occurrence and Haddonfield or anywhere
mr. riddle was watching you Laurie mr.
riddle is 87 I like to think this film
encouraged a giant spike in 87 year old
men joining gyms in 1978 since they're
smoking weed and don't want to get
caught why exactly couldn't they just
keep talking to the sheriff
he's clearly busy and he could have just
driven right past him and he probably
wouldn't have even noticed all they took
was some Halloween mask rope and a
couple of knives they stole Halloween
masks at the hardware store
also what's the deal with this town
Michael's been able to walk around in
daylight all day drive around in a
stolen station wagon that is very easy
to identify
he stole a tombstone from a cemetery
committed a hardware store robbery and
between stops he stopped Laurie
throughout the movie and nobody's seen
this guy except Laura also also Michael
had the mask on when he was stalking
Laurie at school and afterwards when the
girls were walking home so has this
alarming going off all day one thing
this movie does in superb fashion and it
feels like nobody really ever tried this
in horror movies afterwards is using the
edges of the frame to show Michael
lurking around every corner this movie
constantly asked you to search the frame
for a Where's Waldo for the 70s crowd
and it perfectly puts the viewer on it I
guess we'll just chalk it up to the fact
that Laurie and Annie are high when they
don't notice the same station wagon
following them everywhere they go okay
this movie does not know how to time
frame correctly so Michael has
presumably been following Laurie around
all day plus he had to rob the hardware
store at some point steal Judith's
tombstone etc so let's assume he ate the
doll what in the morning when Laurie was
dropping off the key how the fuck would
it still be warm inside both random
thing that breaks a window at this very
moment is random and both we do he's
been here once tonight I think he'll
come back I'm gonna wait seriously this
podunk small town can't spare one cop to
help Loomis out by this point there
should be some sort of news about him he
broke out of Smith's Grove he definitely
murdered a guy and he's clearly back in
his old neighborhood but sure let's
dedicate our entire police force
elsewhere it's Halloween and somebody
stole a mask out of a hardware store
after all why do you keep them under
there
great hiding place dude your parents
will never find that spot under the
couch when they vacuum the living room
all day Laurie's been seeing a scary
dude staring at her at school from his
trademark station wagon from behind this
hedge and in the middle of this laundry
but as soon as Tommy says he sees
somebody
Laurie's lady boner over Ben tramer
overrides her concerned and he spills a
little bit of water on herself and
that's as good a reason as any to take
off both shirts and her pants in the
middle of the kitchen with open windows
all around mind
that was clearly a whimper and not a
sound that would make anyone think a dog
was okay and he might be a bigger dick
to dogs than Michael and he kills them
and eats them for sake I get that John
Carpenter loves him some of the thing
but do we have to watch all 30 seconds
at the opening I mean that's a 30
seconds of logos sin in a movie within a
movie Jesus huh long as this night also
they're making a jack-o'-lantern on
Halloween night what will they do with
it afterwards put it out on November
first think through your activities
Laurie come on I saw the boogeyman I saw
him outside Laurie's disbelief a sign
which is bull by the way this is what
Tommy saw he saw a dark figure standing
out on alone that literally could be
anyone but because he's a kid that
nobody believes he's absolutely right
about this
that Michael also have ninja training at
the institution because he moves so
stealthily he doesn't even make a sound
Lindsay why don't we not stand here
talking about them then get down to
doing that man Michael Myers hit the
jackpot with how many babysitters when
he decided to come back to Haddonfield
on Halloween night which brings up the
question how did he know who all the
babysitter's were when he came back how
did he choose these victims he's been
planning this all day and it's not like
he knows the babysitting situation in
this town
butter all over my closet am I seeing
things or did she simply spill water on
her clothes and it was just a little bit
like even if that was butter it wasn't
all over her clothes like she claims
[Music]
sure you might have thought the door was
open but how are you going to operate
the car without your keys you went
straight to the car we're not looking
for your purse how damp for Paul do you
have to be to forget keys wait a minute
didn't Michael have a copy of the key or
does he know how to use a murder knife
to break into cars and man and he didn't
even notice Paul must be the best what
the hell was Michael doing in this car
for the last 30 seconds to fog up the
windows like that actually scratch that
I'm okay not knowing the answer there's
no blood coming from her throat so what
exactly did he just slice that her ear
also what's the best way to emot-- a
horrible death probably not this Tommy
picks the most insane moment to play a
trick on Lindsay as it's perfect time
he's seen Michael carrying Andy's
lifeless body into the house next door
Loomis gets his saved a kid from murder
Boy Scout badge today and if you are
right what story did Loomis tell the
sheriff about Michael's escape how did
that story turned into Loomis being the
party responsible for first I rip your
clothes off then you rip my clothes off
then we rip Lindsay's clothes off I was
told that 10 years later this guy was
fired from the guardians of the galaxy
franchise yeah but Lindsay's parents
have to come home at some point right
Jesus this might be the least sexy seen
since disclosure but also some pretty
good representation of high school sex
also based on where Linda's leg is and
the direction Bob is thrusting it would
appear that Linda's thigh will be
reaching orgasm in just a few seconds
also also why is there a lit up pumpkin
in this bedroom did they come up here
and light up this jack-o'-lantern or did
somebody else do it and it's been
sitting here for hours based on the
actions of doors in this film I think
it's safe to say scream 3 and how will
we in take place in the same universe
come on out so Michael watch them have
sex then came down here and hid in the
closet just in case Bob checked it do I
have that right because I'm gonna head
up Michael Myers for gambling advice
later if that's true I admit this knife
is huge but how Allah does it go through
Bop body and into the door behind him
having enough strength to keep him
suspended in the air after the
investigation is over the hardware store
Michael stole this knife Ron should be
using this in their advertising I love
this iconic look of Michael cocking his
head side to side when he looks at dead
Bob he's either admiring his own work or
wrapped up in the beauty of what he did
I'll take us in off for it listen off
for murder I mean don't you ever tell me
that this guy while as evil as dr.
Loomis says he is doesn't have a sense
of humor and since he also has a car and
he would love this guy if she was still
what this mother never looked for the
car before this all so how is it even
here we know that Michael parked the car
in front of Tommy Doyle's house even
though we haven't seen it again until
now and the Myers house is not across
the street from the Doyle residence
where exactly did Michael have that
tombstone stash this whole time also
also remember when Michael took Annie's
body into the house he had to have been
setting this up then and he had no idea
Linda and Bob would be showing up but
when he saw them later did he go back
upstairs hi Danny's body and wait to
kill them before setting it all back up
I mean where was this guy stored so that
this could happen what the busy hanging
from and why didn't Michael just leave
him stuck on the pantry door Jesus what
is up with these doors opening on their
own did the slasher killers only case
houses with automatic doors so we get
the fuck out of the house right this
guy's a top notch fortune teller slash
knife expert on the cutting edge of
blade technology and he takes a poor
stab at slicing the sharp heroine of the
movie also she just broke a leg on both
there is dead right no okay
carry on Michael somehow knew to use a
rake to prevent Laurie from going out
this door like he knew it would come to
this he didn't do this with any of the
other victims Laurie's the one he
figured would be the most likely to
escape man people are super talented in
the Halloween verse at breaking windows
with their bare hands I'd send this for
the obvious heroine Falls my running
cliche except I'm still flabbergasted
that she can move at all after falling
down those stairs what the actual was
this guy waiting for the whole time I
mean did Michael ever have the chance to
cut the phone line he's been at the
other house this whole time and he was
just about to catch up to Laurie about
five seconds ago so in the time
Laurie walked in here he cut the phone
line and apparently broke this window to
get into the house I mean this reveal is
a lie
had no chance to do this and even if he
did why did he wait for Laurie to around
with the phone and before trying to kill
her really feel like Laurie not saying
so this is she stabs him was a missed
opportunity I'm surprised there isn't
already a rake propped up against this
upstairs bedroom door so that Laurie
can't turn that off
stab him in the face although you're
right it probably doesn't matter no one
shoots a horror movie like carpenter so
let's review
Michael was stabbed by a coat hanger
stamped with a knife shot four times and
fell out of the top floor of a house and
he's still a lot this guy did come from
two human parents right well maybe not
now that I reflect on it since Michael
killed Judith at the age of six and
escaped 15 years later shouldn't this
read Michael age 21 movie doesn't know
how to math or credits I blame the
chicken you love movies you know you do
otherwise you wouldn't be watching a
channel that pretends to hate movies
made by people who love movies I don't
know what that means
and a proper cinephile like yourself
should get on over to MU b.com slash
cinemasins to make sure you're fully
credentialed mu B is a movie streaming
service with one goal introduce you to
great cinema they offer a hand-picked
selection of the best films from all
over the world movies experts introduce
a new film that they love every single
day and every movie stays on the
platform for a full month and this month
is horrific October featuring iconic
films from Michael Mann Cronenberg
Romero and many more don't think you can
persuade me with appeals to an
intellectual vanity I don't think I'll
persuade you at all you'll need to do it
or you won't and movie works great on
your PC tablet mobile device and even
your TV so you always have access to 30
great hidden gems from cinema history no
matter where you are no matter where you
going
and right now cinema since fans can get
a full month of movie for free I mean
let me take a wild guess here
that's right ghouls Lots I thought so
just head to MU be calm slash cinemasins
to sign up and start exploring the
handcrafted selection of some of the
best films ever made including their
spotlight on horror this month we love
it and we think you will too
I told everybody nobody listened we
didn't let it in 1930 the
republican-controlled House of
Representatives in an effort to
alleviate the effects of the anyone
anyone the Great Depression he got
hungry and wouldn't do that she's no man
tis a remorseless eating machine
I met this six year old child with this
blank pale emotionless face and lifeless
eyes like a like a doll's eye sorry as a
peeping
[Music]
Tomic was a big thing
serious about it aren't you I am serious
and don't call me Shirley cos tan rot
that fate was somehow related only to
religion whereas Sammy when you're a
regular Rhodes Scholar what did you
graduated from again mmm-hmm University
of death I shot him six times